Glen Ford executive editor of
blackagendareport.com
well the crisis stems from the
contradictions between two main currents
in in in black politics one sometimes
it's called the assimilationist current
and that is that the struggle is is
about equality and nothing else
citizenship rights and nothing else to
become Americans and that's it and once
we have achieved this American this then
the the movement is over the other
current is I call the self-determination
astern which recognizes African
Americans as a distinct people having
become a distinct people here in this
country who have the right to choose
their their own political path to
express to try to build a world as they
see it based upon a world of view that
they are entitled to because of their
peoplehood which they achieved in this
country and and often Oh in fact
certainly are all the way through the
60s these two currents ran parallel to
each other in in the same direction
however once we achieved legal status as
full Americans the contradictions
between the two class are the two
currents but the one that would just
like to assimilate and and measured its
progress by how how American like we
were and the other which wanted to
express our view of the world to shape
the world as as we thought it should be
shaped
that's that of course is done
politically there there was a divergence
there this these these contradictions
have come to the inevitable head with
the election of Barack Obama
it certainly is a a profound change in
terms of that current that seeks to be
totally integrated into this American
project it's it does not challenge that
American project a project that began
with with genocide and enslavement and
continues as as imperialism so so for
those who simply wanted to integrate
into this into this American project to
as Martin Luther King once said to Harry
Harry Belafonte run into a burning house
this is the Epiphany this is the end of
things this is the the reason to call a
halt to the movement but for those of us
whose project is is not one is not a
continuation of this American project
from genocide and slavery and now to
imperialism well certainly that was no
signal for us to end our struggle
Democrats he's a corporatist he's
exactly what what he seems to be within
the black community there is this notion
almost generally shared that Obama is
weakened winking at us that he's a play
game until he secures his position of
authority to the extent that he can
become his own man this is when the
brother Obama will emerge and we should
just wait and and and be supportive of
him not to anything that might weaken
him and and and at some point this this
lack of Obama there's more progressive
Obama this independent Obama this anti
corporate Obama will make himself known
we had black agenda report had no such
illusions he is a corporate Democrat who
ideologically and practically is minoo
difference than Bill Clinton or his wife
I think in fact that Obama is pretty
much the perfect corporate guy I could
see him in a very large multinational
corporation with with with with with
with big holdings in the United States
something like a a Ford or a General
Motors or the old Ford in the old
General Motors and Obama would be the
kind of executive who would try to
reconcile the various profit centers
within Ford let's say and and more
importantly reconcile the different
imperatives in that corporation there'd
be some parts of the corporation whose
whose job it is to cut throats to kill
the competition to trim workers
remuneration at every point of
production these are the mean guys and
then there are other parts of the
corporation whose job it is to present
that the the the whole institution as
benign this is this is the part that
says Ford is good for Michigan Ford Ford
is a is a native son Ford cares about
you
Ford contributes to your charities you
see and that's the benign section of the
corporation and all of them have a job
to do and sometimes they're antithetical
but they're all necessary for the
machine to run Barack Obama would be
great at that so if we're talking about
the United States as a Corp as a
corporation he does that perfectly
he tries or attempts to do it he tries
to reconcile the irreconcilable he's
going to reconcile labor and management
he's going to reconcile blacks and
whites and and and browns by by inviting
representatives of each to have a beer
on the White House lawn this is what a
corporate guy would do he seems to he
seems to come from from that mold
is speaking from basically the same
position as Bill Cosby it is also a
position that is quite fine jibes very
well with what corporate power the way
corporate power would like you to think
let's go back again however to to to
black politics and I mean that in a
broad in a broad sense usually the
conversation revolves around questions
of of self-help and people like Cosby
ends and the words that are Barack Obama
is mouthing will always go back to
self-help we need to help ourselves and
this this line of argument basically
rules out political organization of the
people putting masses of people in
motion as as a kind of self-help when in
fact it is the most important self-help
that we can possibly engage in we we did
put ourselves in motion in the late 50s
and the 60s and into the early 70s and
during that very brief period of time we
made greater strides than we had ever
made in the United States of America and
it wasn't because we pooled our money
informed black businesses and bought
shares and in a black star align it was
because we organized at every level that
we were represented and demanded change
that is self-help so when we hear these
pull yourself up by your bootstraps
cliches what we're hearing is folks
saying you don't need to be organizing
and making all that noise you say just
clean yourself up and put on a tie and
and apply for a job and and if you don't
get it come back again and try to get
yourself some education but don't you
dare don't you dare organize against the
powers that be when in fact that is the
ultimate self-help and you're helping
everybody else as well
probably not this is still a thoroughly
racist country if the goal is to elect a
black president and declare the struggle
over I suppose then then you would say
that that that Barack Obama is fighting
the black fight you see there are two
currents and that's what I began talking
about if if you simply want to reconcile
the black presence in America with the
the the larger society that is with with
white rule and I mean rule not from the
white house but rule and all the
important power centers of the country
then then then we have achieved our
victory if if that is not what your goal
is if your goal is is to reshape the
world we live in then Obama is now in
the opposition
there is a role there are there a place
for electoral politics there's
especially a place in electoral politics
for black people who have not fulfilled
all of the possibilities of of electoral
politics there's a lot more work to be
done and gaining the white house is
really not not part of it so I'm not
here speaking about the futility of
electoral politics when you have an
unfinished business that is black folks
still not having achieved everything
that could be achieved within the
context of what we used to call or we
should call bourgeois democracy in in
the years since since the passage of all
those Civil Rights Acts then certainly
it is legitimate and and and a good
thing to do to pursue every electoral
arena but to believe that that is the
only way you change society is
absolutely foolish because that menu has
been prepared by someone else
certainly when we're talking about the
state and a national level so to answer
your question I wasn't avoiding it it
doesn't matter whether Barack Obama was
the best choice on the menu that was put
in front of us we we if we are to accept
any of those choices as as being enough
then we we are nothing but consumers of
their crap we might as well just know we
and we know we shouldn't even be talking
about going to another restaurant we
should be re-examining the whole system
of delivery of of the meal
the thing that is most important to know
for people who who want to engage in
struggle on behalf of their fellow human
beings is that objectively speaking this
system is on its last legs that we are
actually well I think privileged to be
to be looking to be able to witness the
demise of a system that has destroyed so
many millions of people we are watching
it
self-destruct because it always had
within it the seeds of its own
destruction we're watching it
self-destruct right in front of our eyes
and though struggle is always painful
and you haven't you've never won until
you actually have won and it is possible
to become demoralized at every juncture
and it's it looks like the man is still
as much in it appears as if the man is
still as much in control as he was
yesterday objectively he's not and and
once once you understand that and it's
easily understandable if you if you
study what is actually happening with
the world economy and the relationship
of forces once you understand that
you're on the winning side well hey
that's that's a hell of a an adrenaline
and you can make it through to the next
stage
well life is large and there are there's
almost an infinite number of doorways to
helping other people that's what
struggle is all about and helping
yourself that one could enter I was
fascinated by by the story of a group in
in Baltimore group of young people they
they banded together to create tutoring
classes these were all high school
graduates going to college but they
decided that that they could best help
their community by tutoring high
schoolers who were in danger of dropping
out and so that's a good bootstrap you
know help the community self-help kind
of stuff but they demanded that the city
and county and state fund and expand
their efforts and when there was no
positive response they launched direct
action that is demonstrations and all
kinds of direct actions to demand state
function state financing for the vital
work that they were doing so they
combined that kind of bootstrap helping
your own community cast down your bucket
approach with direct action now give us
our money because it's all our money so
that we can efficiently help our own
people I thought that was just a
fantastic approach for for people who
are 19 20 20 years old to take but with
with just a little imagination there
there are other promising doors that
that people can can walk through that's
just one I thought it was very
interesting
I came into black radio actually my
father was a it was a big disc jockey so
he he coerced me into reading the news
on the air doing his during his radio
ships before my voice even changed when
I got into the military in 1970 I
actually had no experience in doing
anything worthwhile or that could get
one paid except jumping out of airplanes
and talking on the radio so so that's
when I entered radio in 1970 there was a
wonderful period the the black the black
radio format had exploded all over all
across the country by that time they
were now hundreds of black radio
stations but because we had just
experienced the 60s and and that
wonderful period of of people in motion
those radio stations people demanded of
those radio stations that they'd be
accountable to that newly awakens
community and so every radio station
virtually every black oriented radio
station in the country was compelled to
hire full-time at least one newscaster
this was a whole new core of news people
that didn't even exist five years before
all of a sudden there are hundreds of
radio news people at stations that
didn't even exist five years before who
are trying to figure out how do we serve
the community and and what what occurred
was a a beautiful synergy between a
movement which still was vital and
energetic and a bunch of young
broadcasters whose job whose self
assigned job was to report on the
movement in that process new leadership
which comes up all the time in the
community found found themselves with
with a voice on the air through a medium
that was speaking directly to their
people not a general format medium
that's speaking to everybody but black
radio that was speaking to your
community and that became a megaphone
for our black conversation that that had
never existed before it it Unleashed or
empowered a whole new layer generation
of leadership to to take on projects
that they might have not taken on before
without the the the presence of
newscasters on the medium that their
friends and family and neighbors were
listening to paying attention to them
and treating them as black leaders black
radio then became an incubator for
emerging black leadership and it was a
wonderful and very bright vibrant time
but as radio consolidated as things
always do under capitalism a black radio
also consolidated and began shedding its
newsrooms in 1973 in Washington DC three
black oriented radio stations fielded 21
reporters
that's a black radio press corps of its
own in that city and and much the same
was happening and big and small cities
all across the country in Washington DC
today there are six black oriented radio
stations together they filled only for
reporters the black radio was no longer
an incubator for black leadership and I
believe that these decades of near of
deterioration and now near extinction of
black radio news has contributed to the
to the leadership crisis that we have in
America who is the leader who's choosing
the leaders you see what I'm saying the
incubator is gone and now the discourse
is entirely in the hands of a corporate
media which is also white even if it
employs our the black folks it's still a
white corporate medium
my take on this is also rather different
than my colleagues I don't see this new
media as being in any way a real
counterbalance to the the hegemony of
the corporate media black black agenda
report for example reaches 25,000
readers per week per issue they're very
smart people we chose them and they
chose us and their movers and shakers
and and we think we we do as good a job
as we can of influencing their thought
processes however there's no way that
that that can in any way compete with
the major broadcasters who also who also
control most of what we call new media
they see so the decline of broadcast
television does not mean that the
corporate voice is in decline
it means the corporate voice is more has
infiltrated many other areas of of media
establishing its homogenizing standards
including new media
if I couldn't if I could use an example
which i think is a telling one it
certainly opened my eyes from from hip
hop in 1987 I co-founded the first rap
music syndication on commercial radio
called wrap it up eventually we had 66
stations this was a another wonderful
period in in black culture all of these
young people who had found a vehicle for
their own cultural and political
expression doing their own thing through
about five or six independent labels
almost all of them in New York and it
took off like like wildfire the the big
labels looked at it as corporations do
to see how they could get in it took
them a couple of years but by about 1990
they began buying up the the original
independent hip hop labels and preparing
to make their big move they were going
to to own hip hop but they were rather
confused as corporate types are with new
phenomenon there these were new numbers
and they didn't understand them then in
1991 one of the one of the big labels
did a study and what they found was
something kind of amazing they found
that the most active consumers of hip
hop were 11 and 12 year olds that's
called tweens in the business these
these are these are not yet even
teenagers they saw that that that was a
fantastic figure
no no other genre of music had had
garnered a a core listenership that was
that young even R&B was 15 16 17 years
old but here they had 12 and 13 year
olds
it was it was this as if they were
struck by lightning they said we will
take over this medium and and tailor the
product for what we now know because of
our study is the most active consuming
group and from that moment on they made
rap product pre juvenile
now what did you vanaya was like what at
twelve and thirteen-year-olds like boys
as well as girls they like to curse
remember when you were that age this
those those Kris words rolling off your
tongue it's almost it's it's it's a very
sensual feeling and so and so the their
product was peppered with gratuitous
profanity in fact they they they began
bringing in very young groups that were
foul of mouth because that's what the
study told them these twelve and
thirteen year olds would like there's
another characteristic of the twelve and
thirteen year old especially the boys
would also the girls especially the boys
however and that's misogyny eleven
twelve year old boys don't know how to
deal with girls and so they act like
they hate them so there's a kind of of
juvenile misogyny that is part of that
period of human development the
corporations understood that too
and so they saturated their product with
with misogynist lyrics so here we have
profanity and misogyny that is
industrially fed into the music I can't
tell you how many times these young
people would be sitting at my kitchen
table after interviews that we would do
with them almost in tears because the
the labels that they were working with
were pressuring them to get Street or
one one young female artist she was
about sixteen years old actually broke
down in tears and said they're trying to
make me into a whore they're trying to
make me into a whore and they were
well we have to break the back of
corporate power that's the project for
all of humanity we can't solve any of
the world's problems except through
human collaboration and the the big
obstacle in our way is corporate power
corporate power of course runs the
United States corporate power and
imperial power the same thing here so in
that kind of light then the the
difficulties posed to to our culture by
profane and misogynist rap lyrics kind
of pales in comparison doesn't it but
it's all about breaking corporate power
the gates affair was probably as
Inaki was an example of racial profiling
as it really exists in this country as
one could find now there are those who
say that we should be grateful to Barack
Obama for at least calling attention to
racial profiling in any form that he has
given us this teachable moment and you
know we could still be having that
discussion except for the actual place
that that teachable moment went that
within days the teachable moment was
playing itself out on the White House
lawn with a couple of guys drinking a
beer and resolving what was finally
depicted as a misunderstanding among
people racial profiling in the United
States is not about under
misunderstandings among individuals a
racial problem profiling is public
policy in the United States a racial
policy of racial profiling in in in New
York City sees half a million
individuals stopped and frisked every
year on the streets of New York 90% of
them are black and Latino now we know
this because the ACLU sued the city of
New York and forced them to come up with
the figures broken down not just by
incident but by race that's the only
reason we can quantify what all black
folks knew was happening many of us of
course were astounded that that that it
was at that kind of scale half a million
more than half a million last year
if the stops and frisks continue apace
this year they will exceed six hundred
thousand that's six hundred thousand
people finding themselves in the jaws of
the law ten thousand a week because of
public
policy that has nothing to do with
misunderstandings among individuals if
we took the Obama model
I suppose the city of New York would
have to invite several hundred thousand
black and Latino men to Central Park to
have a beer with 35,000 cops the problem
is that the next year the process would
start all over again so so the net
result of the gates affair was to
trivialize racial profiling as it
actually exists it's not a question of
can't we all get along in the famous
words of you remember those famous words
it's it's about it's about confronting a
state policy that that puts black and
Latino men at risk of arbitrary
arbitrary action by by the criminal
justice system
a meaningful approach would be to stop
being an imperialist power which tries
to subject every other nation to your to
your will
that's what imperialism is about within
that context humanitarian military
invention intervention is just another
excuse for military intervention now now
I I certainly wouldn't want to be put on
the other side of the line from being a
humanitarian but certainly the United
States is not is not the power that that
decides what regime is humane and what
is not what is good government and what
is not for for other other people since
we know that the United States just like
any other imperial power is making
decisions and and bringing its power to
bear in order to to help itself or at
least the the the the dominant forces in
in the United States
Obama did do the world a service and
many people on the Left disagree with me
but I'll say it I think he did the world
a service with his speech in Cairo
there was nothing in substance of
substance in that speech but he did go a
long way
I believe towards reversing George
Bush's rhetoric to the world this which
which was which was actually aiming an
American racists domestic approach
written globally an attempt to create
false enemies of the American project in
in thinly veiled racial terms in the
Muslim world of course caught those cues
the cues were meant for the American
people in order to rally of the
Americans around this this geo political
military crusade but the way that George
Bush went about it was to was to in fact
incite race racist deep racist emotions
in the American public the Muslim world
caught that and realized that it was in
fact being targeted as as some kind of
subhuman group on the planet it was it
was necessary for for just for the tone
of discussion on planet Earth that Obama
starts speaking to people as if they are
human beings that's not much to ask but
in the kind of it but in the post in a
world that has been poisoned by the
rhetoric of Bush it actually was
something quite necessary and yeah I
commend him for talking to people like
human beings for a change that's that's
not something we're used to from an
American president
domestically I have great admiration for
for Cynthia McKinney she's the former
congresswoman from from Atlanta Georgia
she was just in the news recently for
participating in two humanitarian
interventions or attempts at
interventions in Gaza I don't like the
word heroes and or or heroines but I
have great admiration for her and I
think I think her stories
is worth telling because here is is a is
a black woman who grows with every
encounter with with with the power
structure who doesn't allow herself who
explores every area of potential
progress and even when beaten down as as
she was with her arrest on Capitol Hill
after being I believe set up by Capitol
Hill police made to look like a crazy
woman
and then her subsequent defeat decided
that well just because electoral
politics has turned out to be a dead end
here just because I couldn't even get
solidarity with the rest of the
Congressional Black Caucus doesn't mean
I give up struggle and so now she's
she's remaking herself as as as a a
non-elected politics activist that's at
something like 50 years of age and I
think that's that's admirable
not everybody gives up some of us just
keep on stepping and Cynthia McKinney
has my deepest admiration for doing that
Hugo Chavez of Venezuela a real light to
the southern hemisphere he's performed
what ten years ago we would have
considered a miracle a real left is
coalescing in in Latin America and and
and much of the credit is due to him he
he never lets up he never allows the
imperialist to walk around without his
name tag imperialist he calls George
Bush a devil when he acts devilishly
devilishly and Latin Americans love it
he has become a focus for the folks who
the United States is treated like trash
for centuries and if there's if if
you're talking about individuals who
deserve admiration yeah you go shower
heads
and it involves Barack Obama it's not a
long story in in June of 2003 my team
was working at black commentator comm
every week I would study the list of the
Democratic Leadership Council that's the
right-wing corporate mechanism of the
Democratic Party I'd go to their
membership lists to see what black
politician they had recruited that week
in in the first week in June of 2003 I
went through my usual routine and
discovered that Barack Obama was listed
as a member of the DLC the right wing of
the Democratic Party I was very excited
and I called my managing editor in in
Atlanta Bruce Dixon to tell him about it
but before I could blurt out that Barack
Obama was was a member of the DLC he
said Glenn before you tell me that let
me tell you I just went to Barack
Obama's website and he he's taken down
from his website his anti-war speech
it's not there anymore so we both made a
discovery the same day about Barack
Obama and we decided since Bruce knew
Barack Obama from from Chicago and since
Obama was then ranked fourth in the
Democratic Senatorial primary race and
wanted to talk to everybody then we
would confront him on this we spent a
month going back and forth it's all on
the record and the archives are on the
net going back and forth with Barack
Obama about his being listed as a member
of the DLC why did he take his anti-war
speech off of his campaign website what
was his position now on on health care
on NAFTA and on withdrawal from Iraq we
put him through the wringer and finally
in the end we gave him what we called a
bright-line test
if he could answer these three issue air
questions on these three issue areas
correctly we would declare that whether
or not he was in the DLC or not he
denied that he that he was he should be
or he should not be those questions were
if you are elected to the Senate will
you introduce legislation to withdraw
from NAFTA if you were elected to the
Senate will you introduce legislation
for single-payer health care if you are
elected to the Senate will you introduce
legislation to withdraw immediately from
Iraq he then proceeded over a period of
a week to fashion answers to that
question in the end they were fuzzy
fuzzy mishmash of non answers and Bruce
Dixon and I had a decision to make what
we're going to pass him or fail him we
at that time did not want to be seen as
the proverbial crabs in a barrel people
who were anxious when a brother's trying
to climb up to pull him back down and so
even though we agreed that he had
flunked the bright lines test that he
was not a progressive we declared that
he had passed the test that was a
dilemma and we failed our own tests I've
never regretted a political decision as
much as having passed Barack Obama when
he should have failed the test and we
never made that mistake
you